tout à fait arrivé et vous voulez déjà
repartir ce n'est pas très gentil
pardonnez moi ma chère amie vous savez
combien j'adore votre mythe et jamar
votre côté j'admire votre beauté mais je
suis très pressé et pourquoi êtes-vous
si prince et ça ne regarde pas quel
homme charmant mais quel homme charmant
la bonne éducation se perd même à moi
monsieur du snop qui ne voulait rien
dire que oui non mais c'est à dire que
j'ai un rendez vous urgent avec le
facteur est facteur et va arriver d'un
instant à l'autre ce n'est pas possible
mais tenez le voilà oh oui bonjour
factor ça lui faisait dire à monsieur du
club
voici votre livre je vous ai dit de pam
la mairie a pour sûr je m'en souviens je
devais aller jusque chez vous mais c'est
vous qui ne deviez pas être dans le
jardin je le sais facteurs ge était si
pressé de devenir de chercher que
l'important monsieur du snob
c'est que vous l'ayez votre dictionnaire
des vieilles familles par les plus bas
dictionnaire des vieilles familles bon
ben je m'en vais parce que j'ai une
longue tournée j'ai beaucoup de travail
aujourd'hui
au revoir à mes amis à casimir ou pardon
madame
que puis-je faire pour vous je suis la
comtesse plus lénifiants chanter et moi
et me l'ont pas que je pourrais trouver
ici le descendant d'une très vieille
famille ou pas dans la vous tombez bien
il est justement là monsieur du snow
aussi les stops les meetings une visite
pour vous c'est une comtesse tout tout
est là une comtesse de m'acharner tony
tomassi casimir 7e plaidant un peu plus
loin
- oui oui tu pourrais l'effrayer ben
ouais et alors
c'est ce plat tout à leurs chères
comtesse permettez moi de me présenter
un seul me disent je suis enchanté de
vous connaître cher monsieur du synode
me pardonnez moi monsieur du snob et oui
moi baisse la tête
je suis pas content a crû de myrtille
chantait alors on tolère d'une comtesse
comme moi d'un parapluie ou codis à
kazimiyah les routes est non pas des
têtes spéciale d'ailleurs nous allons
vérifier dans ce livre il ya le nom de
toutes les comptes est une grande joie
pour moi content de vous recevant dans
l'île c'est moi qui suis très ému je me
trouvais devant le descendant d'une
vieille famille autres opéable aucune
trace de comptes est brune de myrtille
pas plus d'ailleurs que de monsieur du
chemin du roy j'avais raison
avez vous déjà rencontré l'artiste de
ses bouteilles c'est une fois médecine
que je connaisse triple peau de chèvre
faille
bon là coûte combien ce livre est très
mal fait ou alors cette comtesse à
invente tout ce qu'elle va faire
attention où il s'accroche
merci
vous devez recevoir la visite d'un très
grand nombre de lots pareil oui juge
oui chers conteste je vis vis des noms
dans le livre on va partiellement je
viens inventer des noms qu'il existe
nombreux sont ceux qui viennent me
rendre visite
le baron par exemple bien souvent c'est
souvent quand je les ai rencontrés
plusieurs fois c'était l'homme cham au
sinistre gay au oui la distinction du
bar de la rue bassano autres visiteurs
vicomte le caramel chico de deux carats
mais vous vous êtes sur six dans le
livre le dico du caramel me rend
tellement visite au sucre et oui il est
un être extraordinaire ne suis pas tout
cela tient sûrement au fait que vous
êtes de sang royal royal
ça veut dire que j'ai vu un roi dans ma
famille je sais même que vous en avez eu
plusieurs religions mais ce n'est pas
possible je ne peux y croire mais le
croyez pas messieurs du stop vous n'avez
aucun voix dans votre famille que l'on
va voyons chers amis de la comté seniors
ou pauvre monsieur 19
il n'y a pas de gros test dans le livre
les grandes familles
il n'y a aucune trace de la comtesse rue
de myrtilles
enfin le col et le vicomte on est
content d'aller la rue bar est possible
c'est un an j'ai inventé et le vicomte
du caramel c'est moi qui l'ait trouvé
pas mal est au coeur de ces options
je suis désolé monsieur c'est vrai je ne
suis pas une comtesse et j'en ai
tellement envie de rencontrer le
descendant d'un endroit que j'ai cru que
c'était la seule façon d'y parvenir mais
pauvre mademoiselle les rois nous rien
de plus intéressant que les autres
chaque personne ne vaut que par sa
propre valeur
de plus monsieur du slam de descendre au
15 mai pour toi on affirmer que je
trouverai ici le descendant d'une
famille royale qui remonte à sept
millions d'années
nous mettons menti non mais ce
descendant là c'est assez mire
[Musique]